few united states senators have the
influence of west virginia's joe manchin
the moderate democrat is often seen as
the decisive vote in the evenly split
senate mansion has shown he's willing to
break with his own party even on major
legislative initiatives leaving many in
the
capital
wondering about his thought process
but the answers they're looking for can
be found or heard far outside the
beltway on a radio show broadcasting
from morgantown west virginia scott
mcfarland has the story
in a political year unlike any other
when people in washington want to know
the fate of the biggest votes they
listen to a man in morgantown west
virginia
a man named hoppy this is all very
peculiar for me because
i've been doing this forever for nearly
40 years happy kircheval has hosted a
local radio talk show very busy show
today heard statewide in west virginia
but this year hoppy has the keys to the
political castle
because of his frequent guests please
welcome you as senator joe manchin
senator good morning how are you home
state senator joe manchin i'm not going
to do something in overreach that causes
more problems
in a 50-50 u.s senate evenly divided
between democrats and republicans
manchin a moderate democrat is the
pivotal vote and at the center of
seemingly every big debate
swarmed by media at every stop in the
capitol this year manchin chooses to
reveal many of his big decisions to
hoppy you talk to him first i talked to
hoppy first because i know i'm talking
to west virginia when i talk to hoppy
including recent bombshells about the
nearly three quarters of a trillion
dollar spending health insurance and
climate change bill that mansion
brokered listen now when you know i'm on
hop everybody's listening i'm hopping
right the white house is listening
they're very very
beltway's listening to everybody because
they know
he can get me to say exactly the purpose
of what i'm doing why i'm doing it
kershaw and manchin ascended the
mountain in the mountain states
simultaneously kerchival building his
radio network to nearly every single
west virginia community as mansion rose
from state official to national
political figure people start to assume
i'm the mansion whisperer as though i'm
talking him all the time i've heard you
call that
and and telling him what's going on or
he's telling me we don't have that kind
of relationship i rarely talk to him
off of the air
so i'm not a whisperer i'm just sort of
a vessel but it's not just hometown
loyalty by the senator it's strategy in
an era of 24-hour cable news and social
media that is a significant statement
you are making radio remains king in
west virginia the most effective way to
reach voters in a state which still has
areas lacking broadband and in which 60
percent of the population lives outside
metro areas and hoppy's show even
attracts the younger crowd like anna
carrier who has a cupcake shop near west
virginia university and who was born
after hoppy's radio show was everybody
in morgantown knows who hoppy is
absolutely hoppy is a pillar of the
community he's the voice of morgantown
so yes he's very well known kircheville
has learned the art of trying to pin
down mansion are you running for
reelection in 2024
i'm running to support the people of
west virginia is that a yes he has an
authenticity i've never seen in in the
industry
you know
we all know
we all know hoppy
we know his love of the state next year
after the elections the margins and the
control of the u.s senate might shift
which means joe manchin might not be so
pivotal but for the rest of 2022 one
good way to read the landscape of
american politics is from up here
in the mountains
for cbs saturday morning i'm scott
mcfarland in morgantown west virginia
kind of like happy he's direct to the
point
has his source well he's been doing it
for so long yeah i still
on the road love listening to i mean
there's nothing like listening to a good
radio program oh yeah that's for sure
very true